oh there's one more photo I thought was  was funny  there's pictures hung all over the walls  of like portraits of the players who  play the top events  so it's great that they put Hans and  magnets next to each other  anyway it's time for duck chess  okay  I could play Reverse bird bath five no  that's not appearance an angry goose  oh welcome back to wander  happy 26 months shout out to Wanderer  too  uh let's play can I play this  it's actually interesting  and then like this  do this  okay now I played this  and this  we're playing three two so I have to  be somewhat cognizant of time  I'm 20 points away from uh  becoming a duck expert  oh okay this is this is a fun opening  trap Knight D3 ducky 2  smothered duck meat  I discovered this trap yesterday after  someone tried it against me  yeah someone call an ambulance  this king is getting smothered by the  duck  quack quack  oh  it's such a fun opening trap like  especially winning as black and five  moves